you better believe Lionel Richie will
party all night long Monday night at the
Grammys and you know a big tribute is
planned for the super star who's being
honored as MusiCares Person of the Year
yeah this is the man who has sold more
than 100 million albums and scored five
number-one hit yes he has but of course
the thing that everyone wants to know
will there be a lionel richie adele
mash-up of their two versions of hello
that would be so great well Michelle
Turner asked mr. Richie himself
hello if I were a betting woman I would
say maybe Lionel Richie would show up
with her now I want you to put your bet
on too hard now see though no no I don't
think so
this is gonna be her evening to shine I
can pretty much think that she would
probably not want to share the stage too
much with great but we'll see we finally
get to meet for the first time because
we have not seen each other do this to
this day you've never met him never met
Lionel will receive his music cares
honor at a big celebration on Saturday
the Grammy charity provides money to
artists who have fallen into hardship or
addiction past honorees include Sir Paul
Streisand and Dylan what is an honor
like this mean to you well you have to
know that I was a little paranoid does
this mean they're saying goodbye an
all-star tribute to Lionel is also plans
for Monday's Grammys on CBS and well we
kind of played the spoiler but in that
tribute there's John Legend Demi
Lovato's Luke Bryan and Meghan Trainor I
didn't know that you'll give me an
insight you know do you have any say and
who gets to perform for you no I well in
this case I like the surprise well we
have an exciting new way for you to
check out all the grand these stars like
ET on Facebook for exclusive 360 degree
videos from Monday's red carpet